INVESTIGATION.
>> Gregg: THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH ME.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE FORMER
ATTORNEY BRET TOLLMAN AND
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN MATT
GAETZ.
THERE IS ALREADY A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL AGAINST NELLIE OHR
AND PROBABLY SHOULD BE ONE
AGAINST BRUCE OHR IN MY
JUDGMENT.
WE'LL WAIT TO SEE.
I WANT TO TACKLE ANOTHER
SUGGEST WITH YOU.
CONGRESSMAN GAETZ WE LEARNED
YOU CAN READ ABOUT IN "THE
DAILY CALLER" THAT ACCORDING
TO A SENATE REPORT, EVERY
SINGLE HILLARY CLINTON E-MAIL
WAS SENT SECRETLY TO A CRYPTIC
GMAIL ADDRESS, INCLUDING
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
SO YOU HAVE POTENTIALLY
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS THAT ARE
SENSEIVETIVE, IF NOT
CLASSIFY -- SENSITIVE, IF NOT
CLASSIFIED THAT CAN BE HACKED
ON A GOOGLE SERVER.
INTELLIGENT AGENT DISCOVERED
IT.
NOTIFIED PETER STROZK WHO WAS
"DISINTERESTED AND
DISMISSIVE."
CONGRESSMAN, HOW CAN THAT BE?
>> THE REASON THIS IS THE CASE
IS BECAUSE THEY ALL THOUGHT
HILLARY CLINTON WAS GOING TO
WIN.
REMEMBER, GREGG, THE TRUMP
RUSSIA ALLEGATIONS WEREN'T THE
CRIME.
THEY WERE THE COVER-UP.
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE FOLKS AT
THE F.B.I. AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE THOUGHT THEY WOULD
BE RETALIATED AGAINST BY A
FUTURE PRESIDENT HILLARY
CLINTON IF THEY AGGRESSIVELY
PURSUED THE FACTS AND APPLIED
THE LAW WHEN IT RELATED TO HER
UNLAWFUL CONDUCT WITH HER
E-MAILS.
THE REASON WE GET THIS DRIP BY
DRIP IS YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO
WERE PAVING A YELLOW BRICK
ROAD TO EXONERATION FOR
HILLARY CLINTON THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DOING THEIR JOB.
THAT IS BECAUSE SUSAN G.
THAT IS BECAUSE JUSAN G.
THAT IS BECAUSE JAMAN G.
THAT IS BECAUSE JAMES G.
THAT IS BECAUSE JAMES C.
THAT IS BECAUSE JAMES COMEY
CURATED AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
THEY WERE NOT DOING
INVESTIGATIONS AT THE F.B.I.
THEY WERE TRYING TO SHAPE
PUBLIC OPINION.
WHEN YOU SEE THE BIAS THAT WAS
SO EVIDENT OF THOSE
INVESTIGATING HILLARY CLINTON
THERE IS NO EXCUSE FOR THE
OUTCOME SHE WASN'T FORCED TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE BAD CONDUCT.
>> Gregg: IF YOU HAVE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS ON A
GOOGLE SERVER, I MEAN
EVERYBODY HAS GOT IT.
INCLUDING THE RUSSIANS.
WE NOW ALSO KNOW THAT THE
CHINESE APPARENTLY HACKED
HILLARY CLINTON'S CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
ONCE AGAIN, THE F.B.I. IS
NOTIFIED OF THIS.
THEY DIDN'T CARE.
ISN'T THAT JUST THE
QUINTESSENTIAL MALFEASANCES OF
THE F.B.I.?
>> I KNOW A HUNDRED AGENTS AND
EXECUTIVES OF THE F.B.I. THAT
WOULD HAVE REACTED DIFFERENTLY
THAN PETER STROZK DID.
AND WOULD HAVE PLACED THIS AT
THE TOP OF THEIR PRIORITY
LIST.
THE BOTTOM LINE ON CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, THINK ABOUT THIS,
GREGG.
TAKING ANY CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AND MISHANDLING IT
TO SUMMARIZE WHAT THE LAWS
STATE, MISHANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION IS A
CRIME IN THIS COUNTRY.
PERHAPS THE ONLY ONE THAT IS A
BIT RELIEVED TONIGHT IS
HILLARY CLINTON BECAUSE THE
STORY DOESN'T SEEM TO COME
BACK TO FOCUS ON THE FACT THAT
SHE HAS A PRIVATE SERVER.
AND THESE E-MAILS ARE ON A
PRIVATE SERVER.
THOSE E-MAILS END UP GOING TO
A MORE PUBLIC PLACE.
BY HER INSTRUCTION, YOU HAVE
TO BELIEVE IT'S BY HER
INSTRUCTION.
SHE HIRED THE COMPANY.
THEY PUT IT ON THE PUBLIC
PLACE FOR ANYONE TO
POTENTIALLY SEE IT.
LET'S FACE IT RIGHT NOW, AND
BACK THEN, CHINA IS ABSOLUTELY
ONE OF OUR TOP THREATS TO THIS
COUNTRY'S NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> Gregg: PAUL KOMBATA THE
I.T. GUY THAT WORKED FOR
HILLARY CLINTON.
UNBELIEVABLY, CONGRESSMAN, HE
GOT IMMUNITY FROM THE F.B.I.
IN EXCHANGE FOR NOTHING, WHICH
IN MY ALMOST 40 YEARS OF A
LAWYER I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF
THAT, NEVER SEEN THAT BEFORE.
HE GETS IMMUNITY FROM
PROSECUTION.
ABLE NOW
ANLE NOW
ANDE NOW
AND NNOW
AND NOWW
AND NOW HE IS REFUSING TO
COOPERATE OR EVEN TALK TO THE
D.O.J. INSPECTOR GENERAL.
>> WELL, WHEN WE IN THE
CONGRESS SAW THE IMMUNITY
DEALS THAT WERE GIVEN NOT ONLY
IN THIS INSTANCE BUT TO A
VARIETY OF OTHER HILLARY
CLINTON ASSOCIATES, YOU WONDER
WHAT WAS BARGAINED FOR.
IMMUNITY DEAL IS EXCHANGE FOR
EVIDENCE THAT LEADS TO A HIGH
PROFILE OR A HIGH PRIORITY
TARGET THAT THEY HAVE IN A
CASE.
BUT YOU SAW THE BLANKET
IMMUNITY DEALS GIVEN TO
PEOPLE.
IT DIDN'T GIVE THEM MORE OF AN
INCENTIVE.
IT CREATED LESS OF AN
IT WAS DRAWN TO CRITIQUE BY
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL WHEN HE
ANALYZED THE BIAS THAT EXISTED
HERE AND THE EXTENT TO WHICH
THE BIAS COULD HAVE IMPACTED
THE OUTCOME OF THE CASE.
>> Gregg: YOU CAN HAVE THE
LAST WORD BECAUSE I HAVE 30
SECONDS LEFT.
THIS IS AS CROOKED AS THE DAY
IS LONG, ISN'T IT?
>> IT IS.
IN 20 YEARS OF PRACTICING
FEDERAL CRIMINAL LAW, I WAS
NEVER ABLE TO GET BLANKET
IMMUNITY.
NOT FOR A COOPERATOR THAT I
WANTED D.O.J. TO GIVE
IMMUNITY.
NOT WHEN I BECAME A DEFENSE
ATTORNEY.
NOT FOR ANY OF MY CLIENTS.
THEY HAD LIMITED IMMUNITY AND
THEY ALWAYS HAD TO GIVE
SOMETHING UP THAT WAS
SUBSTANTIAL.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS FAILURE
THAT IS STARTING TO PERCOLATE
UP AT MULTIPLE LEVELS.
IT'S JUST THE BEGINNING.
>> Gregg: YEAH.
THIS WAS JAMES COMEY'S F.B.I.
THE SANCTIMONIOUS AND THE
GLORIOUS FORMER F.B.I.
DIRECTOR.